and as i detail have chapter four in my
book live free or die
guess what socialism a history of
failure one thing is certain
regardless of whatever name they call it
whatever country they've tried it
lofty promises that everything is going
to be taken care of
socialism always always results in
broken promises
widespread misery yup dramatic increases
in poverty
carnage corruption loss of freedom
and one party rule every single marx
estate throughout history is an utter
failure
still in order to shore up his radical
base
the very weak joe biden is now bowing
down to these extremists
and biden of course tapping bernie
sanders as his chief economic
are literally plagiarizing as usual
bernie's socialist platform word for
word
remember bernie sanders he used to be a
pariah not long ago inside the
democratic party an outlier
you know he's just a socialist and they
just it was a coalition together with
the democrats
he was just basically tolerated among
party leadership but an annoyance
every step of the way from vermont who
pretty much had
insane socialist ideas now he's calling
the shots inside the biden campaign
because joe is desperate
and as the president called it the biden
bolshevik bernie
manifesto now maybe that's why biden is
also adopting the radical left's war on
police
that's why joe said remember the police
have become the enemy
he said funding absolutely will be
redirected away from law enforcement
how do you think that's going to work
out in seattle or any of these other
cities
and by now supporting zero dollar bail
for criminals
and yesterday on twitter suggesting that
michael brown
remember the ferguson incident was
killed because of racist police
he tweeted quote it's been six years
since michael brown's life was taken in
ferguson
reigniting a movement we must continue
the work of tackling systemic racism and
reforming policing
in 2015 biden's own doj actually
concluded
that officer darren wilson acted in
self-defense
and after an investigation there they
concluded that
that shooting was justified by the way
it wasn't biden and barack or joe and
barack
that implemented police reform and
criminal justice reform
that would be donald trump they had
eight years they had baltimore as well
they did nothing and he was also cleared
by the way darren wilson of dewey
by of wrongdoing by two state
prosecutors in their investigation
now with this one tweet the biden
campaign is merely fueling fire against
police officers
over 2 000 now injured 14 dead
for another way by the way biden's
statements and stated policies
they end up supporting the anti-police
anarchist just listen he's never said a
good word that i've heard about police
the 99 percent that protect and serve
and put their lives on the line for us
you know the 911 cops
that were going up as everybody went
down or the cops that
went out in an open ball field against a
guy
in camouflage and hiding with a with a
rifle
almost a death sentence but they did it
anyway and of course we know what
happens
when those in charge work to dismantle
and demonize law enforcement
well look at the great city of portland
73 days and counting city council there
working to defund the police also and
for weeks
city leaders refusing to stop violent
riots at a federal courthouse downtown
well this weekend rioters struck again
torching a police union building
meanwhile in new york city comrade de
blasio slashing the city's police budget
by a billion dollars disbanding the
prestigious
undercover most successful anti-crime
unit also teaming up with
governor cuomo letting violent criminals
out of jail with
zero bail policies new now shootings in
new york have
nearly doubled over 2019 they've already
as of august 1
surpassed all the shootings a year ago
there's still five months to go
then there's the city of chicago they're
refusing
to prosecute scores of violent
perpetrators altogether
you have cook county state attorney kim
fox has now dismissed
more than 25 thousand felony cases
including murder charges
and other serious offenses well that's
35 percent more dismissals than her
predecessor
as a result yep murders are up 55
percent
shootings up 45 percent and just this
weekend mobs of criminals looting
vandalizing
store after store after store in
chicago's famous magnificent mile area
the carnage and chaos was completely out
of control by the way you think those
stores are going to rebuild and come
back
one individual ramming a car into a
business to gain access and as you can
see
the most iconic neighborhoods now of
downtown chicago
have descended into absolute anarchy
like all these other cities run by
liberal democrats for decades
all 12 all told 13 police officers
injured in the mayhem
two people shot 38 others across the
city what is being described as a living
nightmare
or as others are now calling it a war
zone